all right this is going to be a segment
of contrasts we are going to really take
a tour through the full milieu of the
American political culture we're going
to start with President Joe Biden we're
then going to move to failed former
president Donald Trump and then we're
going to hear from some current
supporters of the failed former
president Donald Trump and I think you
will see that this will really put on
display the full panoply of what is
going on in American politics right now
now I want to start with Joe Biden and I
have to tell you I love the new Joe
Biden it doesn't mean I agree with him
on all policy and there's so many things
I wish he would do that he hasn't done
but he has done many things in the last
three months but what I really love
about the new Joe Biden is he is doing
what Gavin Newsom said has to happen we
can't just be meek on the left we have
to come out swinging because we're right
on the issues and we have the moral High
Ground these are deeply delusional
dangerous unthinking people on the right
and Gavin Newsom said Democrats have to
point that out and increasingly Biden is
doing it okay a Heckler a Biden spoke in
Milwaukee Wisconsin over the weekend and
a Heckler flipped out and started
screaming as often happens and Biden
actually says no no no let him go by the
way if it were at a trump rally uh well
we'll talk about that in a moment but
then Biden says listen Le he everybody's
entitled to be an idiot and it's not I
try I mean it's from the bottom of my
heart
as I said last week
we remain in the battle for the soul of
America
by the way
all right God love you let him go
let him go
[Applause]
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no don't lose let him go remember
when this happened at a trump rally
Trump would go get him the hell out of
here look everybody's entitled to be an
idiot no no everybody's done okay look
so anyway yeah I mean at a trump rally
the Heckler would be beaten to a pulp
um and then Trump would uh say that he
will pay the attackers legal bills and
then wouldn't actually pay them he would
offer to pay we know Trump doesn't
really pay legal bills but he would
offer to do that
um also during the speech Biden refers
to the Maga people as the trumpies which
I think is the perfect combination of
condescending and emasculating
but all can decide
we we did fine no no complaints we did
fine
but here's the point
the biggest contrast
from what Mega Republicans the extreme
right the the the the trumpies yeah
I kind of like trumpies better than
trumpists because sometimes when I say
trumpists people hear trumpets and
that's not what I'm saying
um and then lastly here's a uh a new
little bonus from Joe Biden making fun
of himself for being old
and as I said I just signed in the law
historic inflation reduction Act
[Music]
gone big drug companies but we did I've
been fighting them since I got in
Congress went 180 years ago
anyway listen I
I like this this is what Newsome was
talking about it can't be only this it
has to be paired with legislative
accomplishments and a strong economy and
we have both of those things right now
but this is what Gavin Newsom was
talking about I just didn't necessarily
expect it to come from the nearly 80
year old Joe Biden but I welcome it I
just ask where on Earth has this Joe
Biden been for roughly the last year and
a half so that was Biden over the
weekend now to contrast it let's go to
Trump
so I was briefly on a reality show
called the dish and this is really
pretty funny
um this is a show where Mama June
Shannon is on the Treasure Coast of
Florida she's trying to help my friend
TV star Adam Barda sees the opportunity
of a lifetime there are Frenemies
there's drama there's all sorts of stuff
going on for our Howard Stern fans tan
mom is a part of it it's just completely
crazy and I appear on the show and the
dish is our sponsor today and it's all
just delightfully ridiculous and I would
love for you to check out the show it's
only 2.99 for a 24 minute episode and
you can watch it on Apple TV you simply
go to davidpackman.com Dish let me know
once you've seen it what you think about
my reality show debut I'm curious to
hear from you that's davidpackman.com
dish